we've been in lockdown for a month
watching the coronavirus crisis unfold
on our screens but the peak now reached
the lockdown can't go on forever
decisions have to be made about how we
come out of it and when a global
pandemic that shut down not just the UK
but much of the world our crisis deeper
than it needed to be what history will
say looking at the course of this
pandemic so far is that there was a big
difference between the way Asian
scientists view this and Western British
and American scientists in the West we
tended to say this is a kind of like a
very nasty flu and basically there's
nothing you can do to stop it spreading
throughout the population until you get
a vaccine
whereas in Asia they thought this is a
from the Tsar's family it is a deadly
virus and has to be stopped at all costs
the UK late to lock down according to
this global health expert I was very
alarmed on it was March the 12th at the
press conference when they said they
were stopping testing of minor symptoms
stopping contact tracing and also not
making any movement in terms of stopping
large events or even non-essential
travel at that point it seemed they were
following the flu playbook which assumes
that everyone will get it and it'll
become endemic and you hope some kind of
immunity builds up we don't know if
you're you have immunity for a few
months a few years maybe none at all
these are just open questions and so I
think when you don't know the best
things to be precautionary and say we
keep our case numbers low and contain it
and get more information
differences in approaches early on now
as government's learn more about kovat
19 there's a new consensus managing it
involves testing tracing and isolating
the disease wherever the government the
aim is the same no one wants a second
wave look around the world and see the
countries that have managed to exit the
kind of very draconian lockdown that we
have here and they've all done it by
replacing a blanket lockdown with a
system where anyone who has covered
symptoms gets tested immediately anyone
they've been in contact with also gets
tested
anyone who has it gets isolated and
run teams immediately and that is really
the only way if you look around the
world that you can effectively and
safely exit the kind of lockdown that
we're in safety the first priority but
there is time pressure to lock down in
itself is harmful to the economy and the
longer the shutdown the worse the damage
it's clearly the case of the economic
consequences of the lockdown and of
continuing the lockdown are staggeringly
bad we know that the economy is likely
to shrink over the next two or three
months more than it is essentially ever
shrunk before and it's not just the
economy that will suffer from a long
lockdown our health will too the real
worry is people not going to their GP
when they've got a lump in their breast
not getting spare tests done and in my
area referrals under the two-week cancer
target are down by three-quarters so
that could mean potentially we're
missing three-quarters of the cancers
that we would ordinarily have got we may
well end up with a lot of additional
health problems a lot of additional
deaths in the long run which we won't
they'll bursae that person was killed by
a lot but we will know statistically but
many more people will suffer from
chronic disease suicide but I do think
that those things matter and really do
need to be in what sounds like a very
brutal calculus but I think we have to
be rational and cold-blooded to some
extent we've seen this tension between
economy and health and you know
economists saying it's not such a big
deal and health people saying we need to
lock downs and this is the wrong debate
we should be having the economy of fix
lives and if you want to get through
this faster the fastest way to do it is
to keep numbers lower and so I feel like
everyone wants the same thing which is
if you keep numbers low you can reopen
the economy you can reopen society in a
way that's safe because you can you test
race isolate techniques which only work
if you have a small number of cases we
get to a situation in which the Health
Service begins to become overwhelmed you
immediately will have to get straight
down to another severe lock time
possibly even more severe than this one
an outcome that must be avoided but how
does the government plan to do it does a
proper scaled up testing and tracing
system have to be up and running before
you're even countenance easing the
lockdown do you intend to establish what
you think is a tolerable level of
community transmission or is your aim to
push daily new cases as low as possible
to control the virus both of those
questions are are for ultimately for
politicians because they are the big
judgments what I would say is that test
track and trace can done effectively can
help to suppress the transmission in a
way that allows you then to have lesser
social distancing rules and and
critically test track and trace works
more effectively when the rate of new
cases is lower we're a long way from
normal with no vaccine in sight for a
year perhaps ever we have to learn to
live with kovat 19 the government has
worked hard to keep us locked down in
order to protect the NHS but soon
they're going to have to try to convince
us all that it's okay to come outside
again to places like this and that could
prove difficult people are scared as one
senior minister said to me the messaging
has been stay at home and live go
outside and die and now the government
have to try to tilt that narrative the
cost of this crisis will be countered in
both currency and lives the question now
for the government how much can we
afford better ik b Sky News Westminster